Does that ever came up twice?
It's very.
I'll do it.
Just things very clunky.
It's ustream thing.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much for tuning in my
guest this week,
the lovely and talented Mr Doug Benson,
Benson,
everybody.
Before we get started,
we have to mention that the show is
being sponsored by the fleshlight.
Doug Benson.
Have you ever fucked one of these
things?
I have not.
I heard you and Dane Cook talking about
it last week.
There were awesome and it's really like
takes masturbation to a whole new level.
It seems,
you know,
it's a very embarrassing thing to
purchase.
It seems like that.
Has that one been used or is that just.
Would never do that to.
Is that just the recent.
Well,
not that you would necessarily mess it
up just by holding it or whatever
because you don't have to touch
anything.
I mean,
no one's fucked.
It wouldn't give you one at someone's
thoughts.
Good.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's wrong.
Right.
Have you ever fucked a nine tastes
flashlight one?
No.
Like I just fucked one of the other day.
Completely different.
It fucks it.
It doesn't feel anything like better or
worse.
Way Worse.
Yeah.
Somebody else told me,
I think it was half ron so that he
fucked a,
a knockoff for a fake flashlight.
You said it wasn't working,
but these are outstanding research and
it'd be awesome.
But now I totally get what you were
saying last week about how it just
doesn't,
it just doesn't feel right in terms of
you feel bad about yourself or
embarrassing.
Yeah.
Because it's fun.
That's one thing.
Like I guess he'd get a little bit of A.
I've had other light arm workout,
but take it back.
Right.
Turn my volume up.
I've had other people,
um,
uh,
talk to me about this thing and it's a,
it's an embarrassing thing.
They're like,
why would you want to be represented by
this rubber vagina?
Like he keeps coming up.
It came up with like another person that
was thinking about sponsoring the show.
They don't want to be connected with the
flashlight.
Really?
That's so weird.
To me.
It's childish.
It really childish.
Now you just get that,
that company and fleshlight to outbid
each other until
like that.
But then you would never know.
I mean,
you know,
then you show no loyalty to something
that you actually believe if you don't
believe there's anything wrong with
fucking this thing and you want to
protect.
It's like one of those things where
people don't want to talk about sexual
things because somehow or another
talking about sexual things and it makes
people uncomfortable.
It's creepy,
but it's a natural part of life and like
most rational people at a certain point
in time,
just to kind of accept that and then you
can joke about it and go,
hey,
I fucked this rubber pussy.
Ha Ha.
Is it good?
Yeah,
that's great.
You should try it.
And then everything's good.
But for some people it never gets to
that place.
Nevertheless,
I think it depends on how comfortable
you are with like other men like who you
kind of came up with and if you all talk
to each other that way or not,
you know,
like I had a lot of fairly prudish
friends,
like we'd say dirty things,
but we wouldn't admit to any of our own
personal activities the way that I've
seen other groups of friends do it,
you know,
like you see these packs of people that
all just have a different code about,
you know,
whether they fucked a prostitute or not.
It's going to come up and one group,
but it's not going to come up and into
the whole.
Totally.
That's so important.
So important.
Hanging around with the dudes are going
to tell you everything that's so huge.
Embarrassing,
ridiculous,
retarded,
all of it.
I want to hear it.
Come on,
give me a little.
Well that's.
You must get some good stuff from
everyone I know from.
Yeah,
but also like there's like really kind
of almost a code of standup these days
is to just be super honest and it ends
up just to be original.
You kind of have to talk about some
stuff that's pretty brutal and out
there,
you know?
Yeah.
You can't really do.
I mean,
it's almost like the Jerry Seinfeld
route has been said so many times and
gone down so many roads.
It's like I don't see anything there.
It's like,
if you want to do standup today,
it's like,
you know,
Jerry Seinfeld as Jerry Seinfeld,
that style is hilarious at it,
but I don't want to see a new one of
those will also.
He sort of teach,
sort of turned it into another thing.
Like he made it popular.
It's more fun now to watch actors on a
show like the office recreating awkward
situations that happen every day than it
is here.
One guy just describing it.
Yeah,
no,
he's the Seinfeld show.
Just sort of brought to life his comedy
and that made him a funnier guy to me
because prior to that he was a pack of
part of a pack of guys that all just did
clean cut observational humor.
Uh,
and I love them all.
I thought they were really funny.
Like guys like him and Larry Miller and,
and you know,
there's a bunch of them.
Yeah.
I was a fan of the evening at the
Improv.
Yeah.
And those guys were on those things all
the time that I totally grew up on
watching that stuff.
But then immediately embraced stuff
that's more,
you know,
like you can,
you don't have to just observe things.
You can experience them.
Yeah.
I want to hear it.
Like really tell me what you did.
Not what everybody does.
I want to hear a dangerous thought to
admit.
I want to hear,
you know,
I want to hear some,
some truth that we can all agree with.
I want to hear something fucked up to.
I don't want to hear the regular shit.
I'll get bored with it.
I'm tired of it.
I want to hear something.
You know,
I look forward to Joey Diaz sets more
than anybody.
I like strong joke writing though,
you know
that that can get me through.
But.
But you're right.
It's like as soon as he starts to be too
much about,
like best as both,
right?
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
I love anyone who,
a great joke writer and a good
performer.
That's,
that's unbeatable.
That's like a Louis Ck.
Yeah,
but you're right about Seinfeld,
like he was,
uh,
he was such a brilliant joke writer and
deliver like in his style and then to
have that show and then you really see
where,
you know,
curby enthusiasm.
Really good to see where Larry David had
a big hand in it too because once I
started started seeing that show,
it was like,
oh,
okay,
this guy is like the king of creating
like really awkward situations that
like,
literally you watch some of his shows
and you find yourself contorting because
you're like,
what you fucking saying?
You know,
it's so good.
It's,
he does such a good job of weaving that
Web.
He's one of my masters.
Izzy.
Yeah.
It makes it up a notch to that.
It's like on Hbo so that the language in
those situations can,
like that's part of it.
As he often says,
you know,
he often says some,
he swears inappropriately in front of
people sometimes that in subject can't
do that shit on Seinfeld because it had
to be all t view appropriate.
You remember when there was the water
bottle in his pants and there was a
little girl and you know,
there was some implication like people
thought that he had a hard on because
the little girl was there.
I forget how he set it up,
but I was like,
wow.
Yeah,
if you listed everything that he was
guilty of in the seven seasons of that
show,
he's done some pretty horrible things,
you know,
like just the worst thing in every
situation.
You know,
like,
I forget what he did to some Holocaust
survivors,
but it was,
I'm sure it was awful.
Shows like that are so important.
Show you that there's like another level
out there,
you know,
like I think that's important for stand
ups though,
don't you think it's good sometimes to
watch somebody else you know,
and somebody really good,
you know,
watch like a bill cosby and his prime or
something like that.
Just to really get inspired or you know,
just really kick it up to another,
another gear.
Yeah.
It's always good to.
I think that's a huge part of.
I hate to give advice to people starting
out,
but one of the things I say to them,
if they insist on having some his watch
as much standup comedy as you can and
unfortunately we get kinda tired of
watching it is after we've done it for
years and years,
but it's still important to,
to kind of check into it every once in a
while because it just ups your game when
you know what,
what everybody else is doing.
Yeah.
Buyers,
you know,
it does something to you makes you
excited about performing that I'm most
excited about writing after I see like,
you know,
I'll see chappelle perform.
I go,
fuck,
I just want to go.
Right.
You know,
it just makes me want to create
shit,
you know?
Well that's the other great thing about
being a standup is when you have that
impulse,
you could just come up with one great
joe could be satisfied.
Like I hate it when I see a great movie
and I'm driving home like I'm going to
write a goddamn screenplay and that
that's just too big of a task to really
commit to in that moment of excitement.
But writing a joke,
well you know,
you're excited about writing jokes and
you write a good ones.
Like,
okay,
I did that 10,
20 minutes work and then you're in and
sometimes they come in full form,
you know,
they'll just come to you out of the air.
It's like a little gift.
It's amazing.
You were talking about that with Dane
Cook about say something on when the
crowd is so great.
The next sentence after the joke is
probably going to get a laugh anyway,
but when it gets a huge laugh then
you've suddenly got a new end of the
job.
I right out of the ether.
And that's how most of my I,
you know,
I do most of my writing on stage just in
the sense that I,
you know,
sometimes I have a joke that's worked
out perfectly beginning,
middle and end.
But for the most part it's more like,
this is sort of something I want to try
to address and then just see where it
goes and have have a,
have a good joke ready to go right after
it if it ends up not,
not ending up getting anywhere.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
I do.
I do both.
How high you get before you go onstage.
I'm well now people think I'm high
whether I'm high or I'm not like they
just accused me of it regardless.
So you know,
it,
it can be as high as I want to be,
which is just,
you know,
it's just all comes down to timing.
You know,
if you have to race from the airport,
if you have to raise it from the airport
to the Gig,
you might not be very high.
But if you're,
if you're chilling that day and you've
got to show at 8:00
and not much to do in the afternoon,
other than,
you know,
work on your computer and interviews and
stuff like that.
Like I get really high for interviews
now.
Like foreigners.
Yeah,
me too.
I love that.
I love being super big because then when
they do throw to you,
you,
you will talk until they,
until they stop you and sometimes
sometimes they don't jump in so you can
really get a lot of stuff in.
I know I find myself like almost like
feeling bad for what I'm subjecting the
interviewer too sometimes because it'll
start on some like really innocent
question and I'll just start going on
about,
you know,
the,
what is the cause of humanity,
what are we here for?
Like this totally nothing to do with
anything we're talking about,
but in my mind what I'm thinking about
is,
you know,
the whole vision of the world and where
it's headed and you know,
it might've been a really simple
question.
Yeah.
They need you to wrap it up so they
could play some more Kesha.
Yeah.
And I'm just super bank going on about
the universe.
It's like it's all coming to me and
these big waves.
I just need to get it out,
you know,
it is fun to get high and then write,
or,
or sometimes.
Have you ever done this?
Have you ever gotten high?
And they went,
Oh crap,
now I'm starting to have ideas and I'm
not in the mood to like,
I'm not ready to write down ideas right
now.
I wanted to just get high and watch TV.
It's like,
now I've got it.
Now I've actually got to go to work for
a little bit because the ideas are too
good to ignore.
I got way too high the other day and
went on stage and went to the,
uh,
I was at the John Lovitz comedy club.
So you think this dude was on a plane
with Lovitz the other day?
Hey,
I got in his eye line a couple times to
see if he knew who I was and he had,
he had no idea.
But if it was like,
Holy Shit,
you,
Doug Benson,
would that give you,
am I,
uh,
well,
no,
I wouldn't want,
I,
well,
I mean he has been in a lot of great
things and he and I,
I've always thought he was funny
guy,
but um,
he,
he was so sad sack acting that it would
be hard to be excited about it.
He's a nice guy,
he's a real nice guy,
but he was kind of like traveling by
himself.
You know,
how that is.
You're just like humping through the
airport,
like,
you know,
just want to get it over with.
Just don't want too many people to,
you know,
I'm sure like he must have gone through
a period of time where there's some
catchphrases that people yell at them or
they,
they'd say you're a liar all the time.
Yeah.
He must,
he must have used to.
Got that a lot.
But now I'm sure he doesn't get it so
much.
But
why don't you use technology to help
with your ideas though,
because I know that you,
uh,
instead of writing it down,
just like talk,
make a movie,
do the audio because that's right there.
And you're starting to get there.
Like I finally got the most recent
iphone.
Oh,
he did?
I made the first video that I ever like
a uploaded on the Internet where I just
filmed myself doing something and then,
and then send it out there.
And uh,
I'm definitely going to do more of that.
It's
smart way to go.
It's super fast.
It's super smart and fast and it's,
you know,
people love content.
They want you to keep doing stuff.
But what were you saying about being at
the love it's club comedy club.
Oh,
I got way too baked.
This guy gave me a cookie in between the
stage Joey.
There were like these little,
um,
what are those little long banana shaped
things called know I'm talking about the
Scotty.
Not really banana.
That's the closest thing I could see.
The banana.
How do you describe that shape already
shaped cookie.
Cookie cookie.
Cookie canoe.
This guy,
I didn't even eat a quarter of one man I
didn't need.
He goes,
they're really strong.
Okay.
Just,
I took a bite.
One bite 45 minutes later.
I was onstage and I was a board and
alien space craft while I was talking to
these people.
I mean I was barely.
They're barely there enough to
communicate.
I was so high.
There's no way I should have been
talking in public.
That's a surreal space when you're
onstage there too,
because of the way they have that,
those,
those balconies,
balconies or rather close to you,
but just up high,
very shallow but high and it's uh,
it's,
it's kind of exciting,
but also a,
it's different than what we're used to.
Yeah.
It's cool.
I mean it was a fun club.
Weird about that club is how the bars
open and so halfway through the show
you're just hearing clicking and
clunking and people that have a lot of
put a curtain right?
Could,
but you know what,
it ain't that bad.
Like San Francisco Punch line doesn't
have a career yet and that works out
okay.
Yeah,
that's far.
Somehow it adds to the ambiance stuff.
As long as people aren't Douchey,
it doesn't matter,
but you are right.
It does give an opportunity for things
to get annoying.
Anytime you have a bar where people can
stand in order a drink,
you're fucked or divert attention from
the crowd quietly because people,
people start hitting on people and
talking.
The last show I did,
like where it was a standing room show,
me and Joey did this show in Memphis and
was like this last minute booking and it
was a,
um,
a rock club and so we're like,
all right.
Yeah,
they have bands there.
Fuck it.
Well,
you know,
I'm sure it will be set up fine.
And the guy's like,
he wants to do standing room.
I usually don't.
I said,
okay,
fine,
fuck it.
The whole half the room was standing,
half the room was seated and was really
strange.
It was like you're standing on stage and
to your right,
everyone seated and to your left is a
bar.
So literally like everything to your
left is like,
there's like 200 people just standing
and talking.
Yeah,
of course you're doing standup in a bar
and the bear,
they're barely paying attention.
They're acting like a band is onstage.
I used to do that,
the house of Blues too,
but now after we went to see stan hope
and we had a stand and it was horrible.
It was like after an hour,
like your fucking back hurts your neck
starts to kink up,
and so I said,
I'm not going to subject anybody this
anymore.
It is.
I feel bad for people when they're
standing during the show.
Do you ever say no that you won't do
those shows and just haven't.
Uh,
I haven't really gotten to that position
where like,
you know,
if that's an option and that's going to
get more bodies in the venue,
gets less bodies in the venue,
you lose money.
But it's,
to me it's better to let him sit.
You mean to let them sit?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the thing.
It's so I am not as big a deal.
I'm not such a draw that they're like
coming to me begging me to let everybody
stand.
You know,
I've been on Comedians of comedy tours
with,
with patent oswell where everybody's
standing and it's,
uh,
it's amazing how much they'll put up
with David Cross standing shows all the
time and his shows go on forever and he
has bands come out and that crowd is,
is okay with it,
but I don't think my crowd,
I think stoners would rather sit down
finding okay with it.
I would.
I mean if there was an only an
opportunity to go see a great comic,
you know,
someone,
even if I wasn't even doing standup,
it was Chappelle or someone like that,
I would stand.
I'll stand for two hours.
I mean,
how often is this guy come to town?
Once a year should I can stand for two
hours once a year,
but it's not the best feeling.
The best way is to sit down and chill.
He sit down and chill and then you could
really enjoy the jokes when you're
sitting down,
relaxing,
everything's more fun.
It's what's the worst is when they have
couches in a comedy club like,
Oh,
here's the VIP seats.
And it's like a couch in the back where
they not only can get loud,
but they also just are lounging around.
It's not the right to.
It's not the right posture to watch
comedy unless you're like stoned or
something.
Yeah,
you're totally right.
I like it when the seats are fixed,
fixed seats into the so they can't even
move.
I'm like at the comedy works in Denver.
I was just going to say that that place
is crazy.
They got those little tiny trays that
are smaller than a school desk or we're
an airline tray and you just put.
They just put their Nachos and their
drinks on it and the people are in there
so tight and it's underground.
It's really.
That place is almost perfect.
The only thing I'd say that I don't like
about it is just a,
you know,
it gets a little rowdy sometimes it gets
routed to the crowd.
Noise is like,
it's so it's a win win.
They're cheering for you and applauding
because it's so loud.
But then when they're talking amongst
themselves,
when they're like,
you know,
losing focus,
that's really loud to Denver's pretty
wild man.
Colorado people get wild.
Yeah.
It's a lot of wild cowboy in Colorado.
I think the alcohol and the weed both
hit you harder because of the altitude.
Fuck yeah,
it does.
You're a mile up in the air man.
Yeah.
So if we try working out up there.
Yeah,
I've tried,
tried doing a lot of things there that I
regretted.
I went to an amusement park there one
day.
Oh my God.
And uh,
yeah.
And it's just like it,
it was fun,
but much more exhausting than going to
an amusement park should be.
Yeah.
I can only imagine.
Walking up hills is tough up there.
I went hiking once and it was like a
full on workout.
Like I was breathing heavy and sweating
and it's like,
this is crazy.
This is not where you want them outline
to catch you while he's out of breath
and shit can even make it up the hill.
That's the way Joe Rogan thinks that
there might be a mountain lion.
My dog.
Oh God,
I lived when I lived in Colorado.
My dog had eaten by crap.
Yeah,
we saw the mountain lion.
I've had weed in Colorado.
You've hidden it at a comedy club and
I've been waiting for the day to go back
to this comedy club to see if it's still
there.
It gets kind of like.
I mean already we're talking about the
other day we started hiding.
We'd at comedy clubs throwing it away
and stuff because we'd never go back to
smart.
No,
it doesn't.
I mean,
and it loses its potency a little bit,
but you're talking about six months to a
year.
It's fine.
It's gonna be dry and you're going to
hit you harder.
You're going to get stoned.
Really?
Yeah.
Joey likes drawing is weed out.
He takes us like a radiator to shut up.
I used to keep it in the freezer.
Really?
Yeah.
I used to do that to bay.
It gets moisture in it that way.
I like it dry.
I like it to burn and make it a point.
The freezer.
It's supposedly you put anything in the
freezer at last longer be like
batteries.
I'm asking you that,
but we want to put my coffee in the
freezer.
I don't know why I do that.
Yeah,
exactly.
There's a weird thing.
I just did it because people suggested
it or somebody said it somewhere and
then after awhile I was like,
why am I doing this?
Get into this.
We'd fast enough that I don't need those
for another generation.
Right.
This edible thing taught me a lesson
amount.
I will not eat anybody else's shit and
then go on stage.
It was known and he's one of those
professionals.
Don't ever know the store.
You're buying it from somebody you don't
know.
Oh No.
Totally.
Totally true.
To me is always like,
just eat half of this and every time I
take them up on it,
it's either much stronger than that
implied or weaker than that implied like
people are never really that.
That's what I like about smoking.
The people behind the counter and the
dispensary can give you a little bit
more specific guidance than you can.
With edibles.
It's always just like,
yeah,
that'll do it in about an hour.
Some of these assholes put too much in.
They need to get Amazon reviews.
You're right.
They need Amazon reviews.
Every time you take a purple rec from
this store,
this is what happened,
this is how much,
you know,
and there was a job in Colorado,
one of the local newspapers to be a
marijuana critic.
And I got the job.
I signed up for it and they were like,
are you serious?
I'm like,
fuck,
yeah,
I want to write.
It was right before we had to move.
But,
uh,
when I was there I was going to go to
different stores and great them.
Somebody else is doing that.
Now they should think they gave that job
to somebody.
I remember reading about it somewhere
that,
that yeah,
that's something they wanted to do.
I,
you know,
I read it on some slab stone or
something,
some website was,
uh,
was talking about it.
I thought of earlier when you mentioned
Doug Stan Hope.
Uh,
it was funny a couple of days ago I
worked at a club and the guy wrote me a
check and I went home.
I didn't really look at it and I went
home and the next morning I looked at it
and he'd written a check out to doug,
Stan,
hope like it was late and he was tired.
And,
and,
uh,
Doug plays that club too.
So it was funny that he wrote down the
wrong name,
like degenerate number two,
forgotten.
No,
you've never gotten a check.
Says Joe Piscopo on Tony Danza Junior.
Um,
I signed credit card.
It's just a flag that like anytime I
sign a credit card,
any kind of credit card slip,
I always write something like,
tacos.
Let me ask you this.
Are you free to change the way you sign
your kids?
You can't say that your t's not a dot.
What I'm saying,
like say if you have a signature,
write your signature.
So it's supposed to represent how you
write it.
Write your own very unique way of doing
it.
Is it?
Can you just decide I don't like it that
way.
Now I'm going to do this with a star in
the middle of it.
And you're just helping them out because
then you could get every letter of the
alphabet so they know exactly what your
handwriting style looks like.
Your signature.
You still writing the same word every
time.
What I'm saying is could you just
totally change it up?
Yeah.
That's what I do.
Every time I changed my sign a credit
card,
I do Brad Pitt or I hate tacos.
What's the point?
If you're totally changing it up and if
that's cool,
if you're allowed to do that,
what's the point in having a signature
that.
Because you have to say,
did you sign this is it's your
signature.
Yes,
I did sign that.
That's it.
But then they say where it's a,
where you're signing that screen thing.
It isn't that kind of a.
At least capturing the image and
checking to see if it matches how you.
No,
no,
no.
It's just printing it on printing it.
So you could just on those things,
you could just type stars in anything.
Well,
when I was a kid,
I could imitate gene Simmons's
signature.
I could imitate freely because I copied
over their signatures.
I was like a huge kiss fan and you
could,
someone could do that with you easy,
especially in those little stupid things
that the credit card while you're
signing your name doesn't look like how
you write your name.
It's not even close.
Who Cares?
You know how I learned it because I'm a
girl.
I used to date type her name in cursive
letters and it took fucking like an
extra minute and I'm just like,
that's it.
You're not doing this anymore at this
drives me crazy.
It's the extra minute at the cash
register.
I just started signing up for her and I
started saying like farts and face and
talk.
I usually just do tacos and stuff with
Brad,
but I'm interested in obsessions.
They've got the new taco shaped a Brad
Pitt fleshlight if you'd like to try it.
Yup.
Uh,
what that reminded me of something.
Oh,
what I do is I have a signature that I
signed for stuff with.
And then when people ask me to sign
stuff,
I just print my name,
but I always try to say something nice
to them.
So it's at least personalized,
but they're not really getting my
signature there.
Just getting my name written out.
That church.
How do you use.
I'm just paranoid about this whole
identity theft.
So you won't sign things because of
that?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's weird.
I mean why?
Why let someone like a gene Simmons
wouldn't want somebody to be able to do
a great job with his signature,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
Well you know,
you should definitely be paranoid about
identity theft when it comes to you
credit cards,
but I don't really think you should
worry about your signature.
It's too easy to duplicate.
Just carry around a stamp.
I have to.
I don't think.
I mean who,
who has the kind of technology is there
today so you can't read my signature and
I think when you're signing something
for somebody,
when they show it to people,
you know,
if it has your name on it,
that's one thing.
But if you're just signing anything,
then when somebody looks at it,
I think it's nice to go,
oh,
that Doug Benson wrote that.
My signature.
You can't read his handwriting.
I don't think it's that they're that
good at that,
at recognizing,
you know,
shit,
I don't think there's,
I think you could imitate it.
You could figure out how to write so
many signature and you could probably
pull it off close enough.
Yeah,
you just have to find it somewhere.
So if you watch them,
if you film them,
do it and you saw like how they do it,
he could just imitate it.
Well that's where my paranoia sets in is
when I'm at the ATM,
the beeping noises that the numbers make
that takes the privacy out of the
number.
If someone was just watching the site
and,
and recording it,
right,
they could figure out the numbers easy
and then like,
you know,
Jack,
you up around the corner and then use
your card and take out whatever the
maximum is.
What did you see?
The new thing,
there's a new app for chase bank that
you can actually scan a check front and
back and with your iphone and send it
and it deposits the check and then you
just rip up the check.
Well that's too,
that's too easy.
What about the,
uh,
using your iphone to check in on the
plane,
like the Barcode ticket can be on your
iphone and just run that.
Yeah.
My fear is,
you know what your iphone is dead then
you don't have a ticket.
Yeah.
And you're actually,
I phones die man.
Especially if you fuck around and die so
fast,
you know,
you make a video and it's.
Your power is half gone.
Yeah.
You got to think about that if you're
using the camera for sure.
But it came,
it's such a great thing to have a good
camera.
The other day we were in San Francisco
and we ate some Chinese food after the
show.
It was like 2:00
in the morning we were outside and I saw
it.
I watched the whole truck.
You tweeted it,
I watched it and I was like,
he must be so high because you kept
saying is the craziest shit you ever
saw.
And I know you're a UFC fights every
other week,
so I know you've seen some crazier shit
than a bunch of strippers in the back of
a sort of weird plastic.
Probably have seen some crazy shit,
definitely,
but it was crazy and I was so high.
Yeah,
yeah.
I was just like,
you can't believe it and now to be able
to just share it with everybody.
You were like double rainbow,
but with a van full of strippers.
Excited about it.
It was so ridiculous to me.
It was such a sign of the times.
To me it was like a scene in a movie
right before the meteor hit,
right before the aliens landed on
today's show is video audio,
timss video.
There's this big idea,
this big clear box that pulls up and
there's girls dancing.
It's a fish tank of skanks and they're
dancing.
I mean it was the most ridiculous thing
I've ever seen in my life.
It's for the Hustler Club.
We had a rewind the video to find out
what the comparable jump over because
they should be sitting while it's in
motion,
can be dancing while we're driving.
You got to sit your little quick.
They didn't really like because that was
what I was waiting for.
His like them having to get out and get
coffee.
We thought that might have happened to
be going to jail,
like maybe it's illegal to do that
because it seems so ridiculous,
but apparently it's not.
One of the things it was funny is when
we were filming the girl and I didn't
film their faces.
I wouldn't.
I did specifically did it say it in a
plastic card.
If I'm going to put it online,
you don't need to see your face on it
for a week.
All that shit on the Internet forever.
So I use their face,
but anyway,
while I'm filming it,
the girl goes,
no filming.
Like we're in the club like bitch,
you're in front of a Chinese restaurant.
Okay.
You're not at the club.
If we're at the club and I'm filming
you,
yeah,
that's a dick move,
but you just can't come out into the
real world in your underwear and I can't
take a picture of that.
That's crazy.
Well,
that's like the a sexy top and the,
you know,
keep your eyes up here,
Mr.
it's like,
well,
come on Jesus Christ.
No,
you know what you're doing right?
You know how the game works.
They only want you to look,
I want you to look,
but you know it's there for everybody
because my eyes are here.
God it.
Yeah,
let's do this.
Popo beale for strippers and you don't
want us to look at you.
It's awesome though.
It was awesome.
It was just like such a.
Such A.
Just A.
First of all,
just a perfect representation of how
nutty San Francisco is.
I wonder if that Cisco's such a,
but it's just that.
Yeah,
that probably no one will complain about
that.
No one.
No one going.
I'm sure some kids saw it.
Oh,
a lot there.
It's just so liberal.
They're so open minded.
It's a weird town,
man.
I wonder if that law with sitting down
while you turning the corner,
if it came from like back in the old
days where it's like a pickup truck and
girls would just fly off the site.
I think you have to have your seatbelt
on.
I think if you're in a car,
you have to wear a seatbelt.
Right?
I mean,
that's a lot.
You get pulled over for something else I
think.
I don't know.
No,
no,
no.
They can pull you up.
I have no idea.
I thought it was illegal.
I was in a cab in San Francisco and the
crusty older lady cab driver told me,
she goes,
if you ever want to drive around without
a seatbelt on,
because she goes,
I don't like how seatbelts feel.
I don't like to have it on.
Especially if you've got big boobs,
it must be an annoying thing.
So uh,
she fastens it behind her back so that
it is because the cops look for is the
glint of the buckle because you haven't
got it pulled down.
You have,
you don't have the buckle.
So they see that and then they put,
they can pull you over for that and then
get you on for other shit,
for glint dude over for that.
And then they go,
oh,
we thought you had your seatbelt off.
And then they can,
you know,
oh,
we smell marijuana or whatever.
If you get pulled over for not wearing a
seatbelt,
you're a Douche.
Any cop just pulls you in.
This is going to pull this person over.
Forest.
I like wearing it,
to be honest with you.
I've been pulled over for that guy told
me to do it really?
And he said,
he said you were driving.